your short form is simply just like
eyeballs and marketing because those are
the easiest ways to get eyeballs and you
can be broad you can do all these things
to get people aware of you the goal from
there is not necessarily to get someone
to buy or follow from that the goal is
to get them to watch now what I call
medium form which would be like 8 to 15
minutes and you know if somebody watches
an 8-15 minute video then they're pretty
bought in like that's you know in
today's world that's good retention and
you know they're going to get to know
you better and you can explain things
way more in depth they can understand
your expertise from there
if you have something that's like an
hour long like a podcast then they're
really bought in you know when I go to
my own events where people have paid
thousands of dollars to be there I
always hear them tell me about a podcast
they listen to and then that's not a
coincidence it's like yeah those are the
people who are bought in they're
listening for an hour and so if you want
to think about like if you're an
entrepreneur or your customer Journey
it's like make them aware of you a short
form you know give them some pieces of
the pie in medium form and then long
form is where they're going to become
you know lifelong fans